so let's talk a little bit about your
YouTube channel cooking a couple
interesting things have happened with
that so you do a lot of direct to camera
stuff where you explain a lot of
evolutionary stuff I mean all the things
that are in your expertise and you talk
about religion and a lot of great stuff
that I love to share
but you've screen capped a couple times
in the last few weeks that YouTube has
unmonitored some of your videos now I
love YouTube the reason that I'm doing
this show independently is because I
wanted to remain fully on YouTube we all
know about the discovery on YouTube this
is where everyone finds us etc etc but
what do you make of what's happening I
mean I've watched I'm pretty sure I've
watched almost all your videos and I've
never seen you say anything hateful or
call for violence or even marginalize a
group in any way any of that stuff and
and YouTube has come after a couple of
your videos okay so so there are two
levels in some cases they unmonitored a
clip so for those people who don't know
what that means basically it removes the
ability for the content provider to make
money off that clip and the reality is I
make very very very little money on my
YouTube clips cuz I'm you know I'm not
the gamer at all member his name P weed
well I think you know 44 million
subscribers 12:4 he's making a honey
tree for me right I mean I can't buy
shoes with the amount of money that I'm
making
so certainly my indignation is not due
to the fact that you're removing the
rights on mine you know being able to
buy a house in Laguna Beach yeah by the
way you didn't even monetize for even
patron I only started in the fall right
yeah
precisely because it takes so much of my
time I mean this is your full-time job
I'm doing this as extra yeah this is
after my 12 hour up to 18 hour day is
when I do this stuff okay so it only
makes sense that hopefully you couldn't
be remunerated and some small amount
sure so what they usually do is they
unmonitored the clip for whatever reason
I don't know why and then you could
request a manual review which I guess
some actual human goes through and they
either then romana ties it
or they unmonitored it permanently and
the reality is that there is a general
theme to the clips let's not say what it
is there's usually a theme to what is
being unmodified so if we're going to be
charitable then I might say that it's
maybe an algorithm that is being used
it's not a human there's an algorithm if
you ever see the word and here I'll put
in square brackets and redacted yeah
right you're saying just sorry the few
people that don't I am saying it's long
yeah then it will get on monetized and
it's some algorithm that needs to be
fixed and updated mm-hmm if I'm going to
be less charitable and kind of more
conspiratorial then there's literally
some clear direction directive where
people are being told removed this type
of stuff so in either cases it's it's
soul-crushing yeah you know I don't know
what the answer is and unless we were
had welcome the CEO of Google or YouTube
or any of these people to come on the
show and talk to me about this and I've
invited Mark Zuckerberg and I have
invited Jack from Twitter and all these
people but they keep this stuff kind of
secret and what I've when I've talked to
a couple insiders at a few of these
companies what they've told me is that
it's not necessarily the algorithm but
there is a mob of people that don't like
you for example about what you're saying
about Islam so they automatically keep
flagging your videos and they're all day
long and they're doing it from multiple
accounts and eventually that flagging
then leads to the either the algorithm
kicking in or whatever there have been
safety you know you've hit the threshold
and then they unmonitored
but that's just as dangerous letting the
letting the inmates run the asylum is
just as dangerous as letting the
algorithm a flawed algorithm run those
and I should say what I'm gonna say next
this reality should not exist
independently of what I'm gonna say next
but if you typically look at the like to
dislike ratio of all of these clips that
they unmonitored it's a strong you know
700 likes for dislike it's not as though
you know people are collectively saying
this guy's putting out bad content not
that if I were putting out bad content
you should be censoring me but the
reality is there is nothing as you said
that's objectionable and what I'm saying
I might be objectionable but that but
what I meant to say is something that
would truly you know I'm triggering
violence against a group of people or
hates fear I'm not doing any of this
stuff and oftentimes it's just
conversations with other academics or
expert oh it has Islam in it boom
unmagnetized yeah so I bring this up not
not so that we can pontificate on our
little YouTube worlds although I do
think that this little ecosystem but I
don't bring it up so that we can just
sort of do insider baseball on that as
much as it shows that there is something
bigger happening here related to free
speech
so in exam you know for example with
Milo being booted off Twitter and just
in the last couple weeks ali rizvi who I
know you know and Faisal and all got
banned temporarily from Facebook Ingrid
caucused who was on the show was bad
enough types of people have been bad
right so I've I've helped some of them
get back on Facebook cause I have a
decent connection at Facebook but how do
you place that threat to free speech
because in America we do have the First
Amendment and you know it's about the
government coming for your free speech
so this isn't government regardless of
whether it's an algorithm or just a kid
clicking flag it's not the government
but these companies Facebook Twitter
YouTube are very in cahoots with the
government we know that they meet with
high-level officials all the time so how
do we separate those two things how do
we go about the discussion in a
I'm unsure what would be the ways by
which we can address it I'll leave that
to the relevant experts legal experts
but in terms of the zeitgeist it's
dangerous right I mean the fact that you
and I might even before we send the post
button or always Facebook and a ban me
for this the fact that I have that
instinct it has never stopped me from
posting whatever I want
sure incidentally I was at one point
myself let me mention this very quick
story there was a woman at Lebanese I
think Christian woman who was sending me
you know but but why don't you hate
Israel but you're not being fair why
don't you hate Israel you have to hate
this real strong and she was that was
progressing progressively getting more
Jew hatred yeah it's at one point I
decided to just say who she was I mean
although she had posted stuff so she was
public I said here's the person who's
the Jew hater you know she must have
complained to Facebook and for one day
they banned me or something I had to
kind of log in whatever so you can post
a hatred towards me right I say who you
are
I get banned so it's dangerous there
should be unless you're posting
something that says go out and harm
these people incitement for violence
yeah that's a no-no otherwise everything
is a go how much is the free speech
debate being had in Canada because
obviously you guys don't have the Ten
Commandments our Bill of Rights
but you have a healthy respect for free
speech and a history of free speech but
it is a little different it is it is I
mean you have a strong additional layer
of protection by having the First
Amendment so in Quebec right now there's
a bill that's being discussed and I'm
not sure where it is in the process bill
52 I kind of a number it's a bill on
hate speech that no denigration of
religion and so on of course the the
driver behind that whole bill stems from
not touching one particular religion
okay
but I won't say it this time it's
actually got the point exactly
yeah but nonetheless it's a very very
dangerous thing because now you can have
a
bureaucrat I don't know all the details
of law but if somebody complains about
you having posted something on your
Facebook page that is denigrating
towards a particular religion then you
could be taken now they don't put you in
jail but they'll find you you know
$7,000 whatever it is well that's gonna
make me think twice before I press that
so it's dangerous and you see it all
over Europe right I mean you're builders
some of your guests who some of your
viewers who don't know who he is he's a
Dutch parliamentarian who could
potentially be the next prime minister
of the Netherlands he was taken in front
of a court in Netherlands because he
said some things that were deemed hate
speech and that he stood up in front of
the magistrate and said but you can test
the veracity of what I'm saying not that
by the way the veracity should matter
whether you should say it or not right
the judge answered I mean if you want to
get goosebumps this is gonna get you
who's Punk's it doesn't matter whether
what you say is true or false even if
it's true if it denigrates at people or
a religion then you're not allowed to
say it
so even saying something truthful right
it becomes hate speech it's grotesque so
is the problem here that we've put
religion in such a protected class that
even when there's a political element
origin and this again is what Bill
Warner focuses on and his site is called
political Islam there is a political
element to Islam that the other
religions don't really have not to say
that Christianity hasn't had a strong
influence on America we know but the
Christian Right is crumbling we know
that right now I mean I went to the
reason rally in DC there were about five
protesters well you know and they were
being laughed at the whole time the
Christian Right has having virtually no
effect in the election this year the
evangelicals Trump went there went to
really did you see that he went to
Liberty College babbled at them for a
minute screwed up some verses and it was
like nobody they've lost their influence
they lost the gay marriage battle et
cetera et cetera but that with Islam
there is a political bent to it and we
can't seem to untie these two things and
that's the danger you're not attacking
anyone for their faith as long as it
doesn't bother anybody else but you're
talking about the political
and that could put women in beekeeper
costumes as Bill Maher says and and all
this stuff and that's the part we have
to fight exactly and again to go back to
my analogy of the person was 20 pounds
overweight and 200 pounds overweight
both are called
overweight if we stop the descriptor
there then they're indistinguishable but
if we say that
how much overweight you are matters then
we recognize that the 20 pounds
overweight is not the same so same thing
for religion or I think sam harris uses
the example of sports analogies I don't
know which sports use is ready and I'm a
fighting as a sport and badminton is a
sport a lot more violent than the other
can be quite right so so the reality is
there is a unique reality to political
Islam that we need to confront and no
Mormons and seventh-day adventists are
not indistinguishable from you know the
nefarious aspects of political Islam
yeah and I mean only a fool or somebody
who is duplicitous duplicitous is going
to argue otherwise it's so clear yeah it
is incredibly clear all right well I
think you know we we spent so much time
and energy talking about that but let's
move a little bit to your to your
academic stuff before we have to wrap up
and you you peppered it in here because
it all fits within the the constructive
way you're talking about what do you do
all day as a professor I think people
wonder what is a professor are you
sitting in a smoking jacket and I
picture you and there's a lot of books
around you in folders and by alright and
you know you care and you're bundled and
kids are banging on the doors that oh
did I just make it up what were you
doing more of an Indiana Jones kind of
thing are you out and doing adventurous
bit of those are many much more so a lot
of people that say we don't know what
academics do think that you're basically
a high school teacher except that the
students are older nothing could be
further from the truth
right so teaching is actually a small
very important but a small part of your
day so I teach students of course I
apply for grants I serve on editorial
boards of scientific journals sometimes
I'm an associate editor of a journal I
supervise graduate students but
predominantly most of my day is spent
thinking and writing doing studies
writing up papers for scientific
journals writing books
so if you look at all of the things that
I do in a typical day a serious
professor can work 12 14 hour days doing
much much more than teaching so one of
the things that I actually one of my
colleagues said that that's the thing
that works for most about being a
professor is that when people tell them
also you're not teaching the semester so
you so you're off if you're not teaching
that three-hour class the rest of the
time we're all surfing because you have
the books they write themselves the
scientific papers they write themselves
right I mean typically a paper for you
to write a paper scientific paper you
come up with the idea you then you
decide how you're going to collect the
data you collect the data you analyze
the data you write up the paper you send
it to a journal and then it goes through
many rounds of peer-review so the
process of publishing a scientific paper
could take two three four years and
you're doing many of these projects and
supervising students and writing grants
and writing book and so whatever I do
that you see as a public intellectual
outside my job as a professor as an
added on it's
I already have a very stressed
professional life and that's something
that I take on simply because I think
that my small voice can hopefully
contribute to the big debate yeah I'm so
going back to our already argument give
a brother a break you know we do a lot
of stuff and I'm not getting paid for
this and I'm not making a lot I'm doing
this only from the purity of my heart to
lend my small voice yeah it's funny
every now and again you know one of the
random haters will be screaming old
boobs only talking about this stuff cuz
he knows he's gonna make money off it
and it's like there's no network that
would put me on like his Fox gonna put
me on him to left is MSNBC gonna put me
on I'm to right or center is CNN no cuz
I have an opinion so they're not gonna
either so it's like everyone they make
up their little ideas about you you're
doing this because of the strength of
your convictions because I care about
this and and I and I guess I'm okay at
it but you know we'll see how when
you're doing all this stuff so
everything we talk about this is serious
stuff you're working hard as professor
all is how do you get some balance in
your life amongst all that this is what
I guess
Sam who's under you know such a salt
constantly from all these people and
wrote a book called waking up
spirituality without religions do you
have any spiritual practices in your own
life or how do you get the mostess that
I would come to spirituality would be to
sit on a beach in Southern California
and experience the elements without
having somebody sending me endless
requests that would be the closest that
I would come to a transcendental moment
I mean I exercise a lot despite the fact
that you probably don't believe it I
mean I love to be physically active you
know I used to be a serious competitive
outfit so I have a fleet so I haven't
lost the desire to exercise so if I'm
feeling very stressed you know getting
on the bike for an hour is the way by
which I decompress but actually I think
that I haven't achieved the right
balance I think that I'm way too
accessible and again it comes from a
strand of purity that I have I feel as
though I owe this person response right
somebody just wrote four paragraphs to
me an email mm-hmm I could do the smart
thing which is ignore it because I
received 400 of those emails a day or I
feel guilty like this guy just took 45
minutes to write me this thing asking me
about some personal thing well now I
just lost 25 minutes because I'm going
to write to him so to be honest with you
I don't think I'm very good at cheating
balance and usually my yearly pilgrimage
to Southern California is where I try to
recharge yeah it's funny I feel very
much the same way it's like I see what's
going on at my inbox people writing
these incredibly personal after nice
notes to me and I want you know I live
this you know I'm living this in the
most humble it's humbling and it's but
it's now you know to me like it all
feels very now to me I'm doing something
that's relevant now and I'm doing it
because I think it's the right thing to
do
but if I was to give much more it's sort
of like a giving tree I could give a
certain amount more and then eventually
you just got a stump I forget how the
giving tree ends but I think it's not
good for the tree right right it doesn't
end well for the tree well I mean and
sometimes because I'm giving so much to
random strangers then the ones that
truly matter which is someone called
your wife
say yeah my wife will see me on the I
said can you put it down and so the
reality is that we do have to step back
and achieve that balance because that
random person ultimately you don't owe
them anything
yeah the machines are gonna take over
they're gonna take over we're doomed
we're doing one way or another listen we
could talk forever I mean we really
could just talk forever I'm gonna ask
you to stick around and do one little
bonus thing that we're gonna do for our
patron people but it was a pleasure
chatting with you as always and you got
to get down to SoCal more often from
your lips for the cosmos all right well
of course I want to thank my friend
God's at and you can check him out on
YouTube it's youtube.com slash god said
and it's patreon.com slash got sad sad
sad we think but will at least put a
link to it now let's do you think he
does not care about money people we just
proved it right there alright thanks for
watching and we'll do it again next week
you